okay in this video you're going to learn
three different methods for solving
proportions so you're probably learning
about this in your class right now and
you're wondering you know what is a
proportion how do I solve for the
missing quantity and that's we're going
to talk about here so first things first
a proportion it's a ratio equal to
another ratio so what's a ratio ratio is
basically when you're comparing two
quantities and usually write a ratio as
a fraction like for example boys two
girls students two teachers you know
that sort of thing you're comparing two
quantities but the two quantities the
two fractions are actually equal to each
other so an example would be like 2/3 is
equal to 4/6 you can see if we reduce 4
6 by dividing both sides by 2 you can
see this reduces to 2/3 and that those
are equivalent but sometimes what
happens when you're solving a proportion
is we don't know one of these quantities
right we want to figure out how do we
find out what that unknown quantity is
so method number one what we're gonna do
here is we're going to say well these
fractions are equal right so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to multiply
this denominator c7 I'm gonna multiply
it by 3 so that it gives me this
denominator over here on the right 21
but when you multiply the denominator by
a quantity you have to multiply the
numerator by that same quantity so I'm
gonna multiply the top also by 3 so this
is going to end up being 4 times 3 which
is 12 and that's what X is that's the
unknown quantity now if you're not
convinced you can always reduce this 12
over 21 you can see that 3 goes in here
4 times and 3 goes into 21 seven times
so you can see when we reduce that
fraction just like we did at the
beginning there that they're equivalent
right okay let's go to example number
two so here we've got 9 over X equals 1
over 4 okay so now in this example I'm
gonna actually go from the right side to
the left side so I'm gonna say if I take
1 times 9 I get 9 but if I do that to
the numerator of this fraction here on
the right I have to do the same thing to
the denominator and multiply by 9 well 4
times 9 is 36 so that's our unknown
quantity x equals 36 again you can check
if you reduce 936 you're gonna get 1/4
so those are equivalent okay last one
and see if you can do this one X
/ 30 equals 7/6 okay so here what we're
gonna do is we're going to say well I
know 6 times 5 is 30 if I multiply the
denominator by 5 I have to multiply the
numerator by 5 so you can see 7 times 5
gives us 35 and again if you reduce 35
over 30 it's gonna be equivalent to 7 6
okay so now this is not the most
favorite method but stay with me we're
going to do two more different
techniques and you can of course use the
one that you like the best
so method number two we've got 9 over 4
equals x over 7 our goal is to find that
variable that unknown right so what I'm
going to do here when you see this
fraction bar that's the same thing as
division or dividing right so the
opposite of dividing by 7 would be to
multiply by 7 of course if you do this
to the right side of the equation you
have to do it to the left side to keep
it balanced so you can see this is going
to end up being let's see 7 times 9 is
63 over 4 these are gonna cancel and
that's our final result so that's what X
is it didn't come out to a super nice
number but again our goal is to find out
the unknown okay let's look at an
example B here so X divided by 2 equals
5/8 our goal is to find out what this X
is right so the opposite of dividing by
2 is to multiply by 2
that way those are going to cancel if we
do that to the left we have to do it to
the right now 2 is the same as 2 over 1
you can always write a whole number as a
fraction by putting it over one right so
you can see we're getting 5 times 2 is
10 8 times 1 is 8 and we can reduce 10
over 8 by dividing the top and bottom by
2 and that's going to give us 5/4 okay
so that's X in this example okay last
example this type 4 divided by x equals
20 divided by 12 okay now this is a
little bit different problem and because
the variables in the denominator and one
of the techniques or one of the
properties of proportions I should say
is that you can take the reciprocal of
both sides of the equation so if I flip
this one over here on the left and make
this x over 4 that's going to be the
same thing as taking the reciprocal on
the right which is 12 over 20 so now
again I'm going to do the opposite of
dividing by 4 I'm going to multiply both
sides by 4 okay and what I'm going to do
on this one
a little bit different I'm gonna do some
cross reducing so I'm gonna say four
goes in here once four goes into 20 five
times so as long as you reduce numerator
and denominator you know it doesn't
matter whether it's in these two
fractions or this fraction in this
fraction you can reduce like that on the
diagonal and so here you can see we're
getting x equals 12 fifths and you got
it so one last example and this is
probably the most favorite we have
solving proportions but before I do that
I just want to mention if you're
enjoying my videos you like my teaching
style and you're learning algebra 1 I've
got a course called learn algebra 1 and
I go through all the different concepts
that are covered in that course step by
step with lots of examples instruction
so that you can really grasp algebra 1
and check out that course I'll have
links to that you can also check out the
13 free previews to see if it's a good
fit for you and pick up some pointers
along the way as well so my last method
method number 3 and that's that we're
gonna solve this by using the cross
product method or the cross multiplying
method however you want to say that and
the way this works is that this diagonal
here multiplied together equals this
diagonal here multiplied together and
what this does when you cross multiply
is it gets rid of the fractions okay
which a lot of times students don't like
fractions that might be might be your
situation as well but this gets rid of
them for you so basically this diagonal
multiply together 10 times x equals this
diagonal multiplying together which is
24 now some students ask me does it
matter if I put the 10x here or the 10x
here it doesn't matter just put the one
diagonal on one side and then the other
diagonal on the other side right and
then the last step is we're trying to
solve for X but because these are right
next to each other that means they're
multiplied together what's the opposite
of multiplying by 10 of course would be
to divide by 10 right so we've got x
equals 24 tenths and 10 goes into 24
let's see 2 times with 4 left over so
that's 2 and 4 tenths or 4 tenths you're
going to reduce to 2/5 so 2 and 2/5 okay
see if you can try these other two
examples we'll go through them ok so
here what I'm gonna do again is cross
multiply so that diagonal multiply
together equals that diagonal multiplied
together so we've got 3x equals 28
divide both sides by 3 okay and you can
see x equals
Thirds and if you want you can write it
as a mixed number three goes into 28 how
many times let's see nine that's 27 with
one left over so nine in one-third right
okay last one again multiplying on the
diagonals right three times 9 is 27
equals 10 times X divide will sides by
10 and 27 divided by 10 is equal to 2.7
when you divide by 10 you just move that
decimal one place to the left okay if
you're dividing by 100 you move it two
places to the left so my goal in all my
videos like I say is to you know really
help you to understand math boost your
test scores and your grades and
hopefully make it a lot less stressful
so subscribe to the channel check out
more math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutor and I look
forward to helping you in the future
math videos I'll talk to you soon